my goodness this is terrible there is so
much bad in this
hi there my name is David rolling to the
London long sword Academy I'm a
full-time swordsmanship constructor and
today I'm going to have a look at a load
of clips about sword fighting and slag
them off hideously so basically what I
have with me here is a longsword long
sword for me is generally a sword which
is held in two hands so it doesn't
matter if it's short or long it doesn't
really matter you have a pommel across
card a grip a blade usually within
fencing we divide that into two halves
but different authors divided into
different and different divisions so
we'll have a strong half which is the
half from the middle to the hilt and
then from the middle down to the point
is the weakest part and we're just
really looking at geometry and leverage
that you get this big thing in
historical European martial arts as I do
where you've not allowed to carry sort
on your shoulder because that's really
really frowned upon it no one would ever
do it except there's actually critique
in manual saying that you shouldn't do
it which implies that people do do it so
carrying the sort in your hand is a very
very good thing and you see this a lot
people holding the sword on their
shoulder and just walking around with it
without a scabbard on necessarily so
it's ready to use I have issues with
this particular fight because there's a
lot of reverse grip with the sword being
held backwards down here it's not a good
way for that you to use the sword you
sacrifice your ability to fend above
very very clearly you have not gotten
your reach it's not safe Howdy's change
grip yeah oh he's back
I like how he moves I think he's got a
good organic feel to him
generally the sort is being moved in
front of him which is a very very good
thing it's very rarely just kept behind
him so he's closing the space or between
him and his opponent with the sword one
of the things I like about some of the
witches fight scenes is that there is
this idea of moving between the
opponents and you see this in things
like God you know where the idea of
spinning something which people really
really quite often frown upon within the
Hema community is very much used because
you're trying to keep opponents away
from each other so it's not just about
fighting you and concentrating and
moving into you it's against driving you
back and then hitting the next person
the next person the next person so these
spinning moves actually become quite
important and this angled sinister
straight into you idea goes out the
window it's not this focus suddenly it's
much more wide and it's a flurry the
thing is most of my judgment on this
fight the fight scene is actually Henry
Cavill being very very good physically
and what is shown in this fight scene
being probably the most disappointing
fight scene in The Witcher so for Henry
Cavill it's going to have like an 8 for
actual quality of fighting is going to
have about 4
[Applause]
so there's bits in there that actually
aren't too bad looking at it there's of
Asians of the blade from the Emperor
which could be accidental but you have
these movements of just moving around as
that as the Perry's coming in that's
actually not too bad you see this kind
of thing quite often you see in
de-stresser when opponents are moving
around each other where a parry comes in
you disengage underneath as it's
happening so you have potential for some
actually quite interesting movements in
there good parry you see that Intel
Hoffa usually accompanied by a wrap
because of the closure in the close
distance kicking up the heels is
referred to in quite a few treaties
quite often accompanied by a movement on
to the door as well so potentially
within this fight scene I'd say in those
last two actions from the cover to the
to the kick with the legs and sweeping
up of the heels I'd say those are
actually quite good actions usually
you'd see more control of the opponent's
weapon arm or their balance with the
offhand as well but that parts actually
reasonably good so for that I'm actually
going to give it a 6 because I think
those two aspects save it slightly
[Music]
okay so again we've got some very very
good bits on this the first bit of this
is the shunting away of the opponent I
really really like this he creates
distance between the two opponents now
you could argue that maybe he'd want to
push the opponents into each other but
he has a very very good instinctive
response push one away get their weapon
from it and then on to the other one and
then a good clean finish on one of the
cuts and nothing Bosh just a simple cut
of wrath in effect pretty good I'll give
that a 7 I think that's quite a
comfortable thing again I think it's
very easy with in judging this from
hemas perspective to get very focused on
an individual and this is showing good
awareness of space maintaining that
distance and then simple finishes
nothing posh so immediately the first
attack is this big smile spin at you
I'll expose my back and the distance is
so bad that he could just be stabbed in
the back
yeah it's it's a broad sword or a sabre
or something therefore you have to go
and cut candles or scenery you don't use
this like this this is terrible
quite often in Japanese swordsmanship
that you're moving the glass deposits
the slag deposits are actually silicon
deposits that can be in steel you're
moving those throughout the entirety of
the length of the blade and through
those foldings you basically you spread
that out so you make sure that your
blade hasn't got one particular weakness
now European swords before we had that
consistency we did something very
similar except that we twisted them like
string so that if one thread was weak
then that's necessary it could be a
problem itself but you're having
multiple threads and twisting them
around each other you create something
stronger that said swords do snap swords
do Bend and there's always a fine point
and you can't guarantee the process is
not perfect even nowadays with much more
clear definitions of how steel should be
made and produced blade still breaks so
it's not impossible for this to happen
so this is where it really gets quite
terrible there's this insane idea that
somehow long swords are really heavy
clumsy weapons that they are not you can
move a long sword much more quickly and
much more dexterously then you can I
rape you it's still balanced as if to be
used in one hand but you have the
advantage of being able to move it
around this position of the position of
the forward hand now even the most
barbaric moment of a long sword barbaric
technique we have a technique called the
strike of wrath which is a strike that
uses the entirety of the anterior
oblique sling so it's the most powerful
strike you can do but it's not done
foolishly it's done as a mechanic it's a
way of claiming space in front of you
claiming that space for yourself killing
with it if you can and then going on to
pursue your opponent through that wide
swings don't serve anybody and they
represent the actual piece of equipment
very very poorly
doing a spin when you're not engaged
with the opponent's blade is insane
because you don't know what their sword
is doing and because you're so close and
you don't know where their sword is
obviously they can cut you freely
because they're still facing at you they
still have all of their requisite safety
in their hands three four out of ten
[Music]
this in case you didn't know is the best
fight scene ever in any film ever
the fencing in it is completely
irrelevant the fencing is part of a
narrative device is not meant to
overwhelm you it's just there happening
while the dialogue does considering the
rocky terrain there's references to but
Nettie's defense I don't even know what
that is but references to Tebow and
Tebow is one of my favorite systems but
they're not showing any awareness of
Tebow Tebow operates on the idea of the
perfect angle that you see in a lot of
Spanish swordsmanship and de-stressor
particularly here where you have a 90
degree angle which is maintained as much
as possible and you don't make lateral
movements with your arms but all of this
is what we call vulgar angles where the
point is higher than the hilts and lots
of lateral movement that's really rapier
some people call it side sort the
divisions are really a later thing we
don't worry about it too much it's a
sword that you hold in one hand now
again we have the quillin's quite often
both good pitches like the cross guard
in effect quite often people would hold
this simply like so without their finger
over the bars and these extra rings
would be to stop things from landing on
your fingers when you're holding the
sword normally and this allows you to
put your thumb on there later on you
start seeing people holding the sword
like so okay but it's not Universal
sometimes it is just used like this okay
sometimes these are very very ornate as
you can see here there's a lot of wire
around here and then sometimes it's just
a simple cup
the idea of being able to fence with
both hands shouldn't be necessarily a
problem fighting somebody who is
differently handed to you as well
shouldn't be an uncommon experience so
this this kind of thing although it's
amusing you don't want to do this sort
of thing at close distance because
obviously while you're busy changing
your sword and your opponent can stab
you and this kind of thing here you have
a bit whereas the blade comes through it
disengages so you having the blade
changing from one side to the other and
in order to fight that what you're doing
is rather than doing lateral parries
like this you're wrapping the blade and
you're staying engaged to it and that
can be used to throw the opponent sort
out their hand so there's there's a
degree of reality and that is good
technically wise I'd still give it sort
of like a six seven even with it's
parody fencing it still has better
fencing and then a lot of the others
that's quite nice because in effect you
have a very very nasty very version of a
movement of conclusion this is basically
where in using a sword to parry here we
then do something with the offhand if we
were doing vote that era the idea would
be to restrain the opponent's weapon
hand so we can control it and we can
choose whether they live or die and we
can show mercy at this point if you're
doing this this is lovely he doesn't
have to worry about the guys offhand so
much because the guy has both hands on
the sword there's a closure off of the
line and the guy giving him the distance
because he doesn't have to move his feet
the guy's gonna come and hit him anyway
he gets to push it aside he gets to
thrust through he's got control of the
opponent's sword still and he gets to
finish him so that I actually quite like
that's pretty good I'm not entirely sure
holding your hand palm down with the
longsword is a good way not to get a
sword taken almost goodness this is
terrible there is so much bad in this
again we're back on this idea that if
you've got a long sword you have to do
this with it and it has to be wide and
spinny and it has to be this big moves
it's meant to be dexterous you have this
idea that there's basically half a nail
the idea of being this kind of space
here rather halfway between here and
here you don't want to be more than this
way far away from your opponent with the
points at all times so if they drive
your way you're trying to find a way to
get your point onto them most longsword
is intrinsically trying to dominate a
space very very close into the core of
your opponent if they move you
sufficiently around you're immediately
back at another opening if they cut stay
tight on the blade and the angles tight
just enough to parry like so you'll try
and drive the blading still maintaining
contact on that all this wide around
movement is complete nonsense okay
knocking the blade down and striking
back up now you could argue that this is
almost a nodding in effect the idea of
beating someone's blade down and in
hitting back up with the full said
here you see where the sword is sweet is
white and one person is standing with
their point right in front of the other
you don't parry then come back here you
stand here and you stab them immediately
because the blade has moved our presence
well that was good yep
if someone has got their back to you and
you have a spear do stab them in the
back of the leg that again redeeming
feature that's that's given another
point so quite like the fight scene
between Brienne of Tarth
and Arya I think that's quite good it's
cohesive it has that real focus to it so
the movement is constant neither of them
is really sacrificing there's no great
pauses there's always I want to be back
in the fight I want to be back in it I
[Applause]
do like in general to hound fights
because they are just like that there
that's good and I think having that idea
that the blade is intrinsically there to
either stab someone or hit them with it
and remove all the sort of like fuzzy
detail is a very good thing to have in a
series
first the twirling is dreadful but the
the blades are all over the place
there's no safety in them and now we're
being focused on a single opponent we
could use the sword in a much more
efficient way even if I were 12 the
swords towards you you'd always want one
blade in presence always one blade doing
something never having the swords over
here at that point I think the idea of
restrained two weapon hands becomes more
important than actually take from the
weapons out of the hand so at that point
I would suggest that potentially you're
looking at a way of either throwing the
opponent as far from you as possible
throwing them and down the really big
hole on the other side of you might be a
good thing
[Music]
yep she's dead now
yeah you're really looking at just
absolute theater here and that's that's
fine it is what it is but it's it's
terrible terrible sword fighting this
idea of driving people apart to fight so
you don't want to be standing still you
don't want big people to be managing the
space what your space is getting more
and more cramped
one of the things that is misunderstood
quite often is that in pattern-welded
plates quite often these were given Mira
polishes and I believe unless this is
anecdotal that there's reference to
people blowing on the blades so that the
the breath actually brings out the
pattern weld for a moment so you can see
it
so yeah blades historically are
incredibly highly polished in various
different places certainly in Japanese
swords that's the thing certainly
European sorta something interesting
tactical decisions here so you have a
point where somebody has control of the
blade and if you think like a paring
daggers you have rib have really options
to take the blade of the opponent on
your dagger or to take them on your
sword and to attack them with the other
but in order to do so you'd want to
maintain that contact so to do an action
like this with your opponent's blade
still directly in the middle doesn't
make any sense really so you had a point
of control or a point of control both of
those been sacrificed
it's amazing that one of these people
didn't die in the process of this they
should obviously I've been disemboweling
or a stab or whichever all the other
person should have plows straight
through the middle in the space before
from the votive viewpoint of a good
cohesive fight scene that involves
realistic technique I'm gonna give that
to
[Music]
okay the first miracle of this fight is
that they don't manage to kill each
other there there are forms which
consist about fighting around somebody
usually that other person is disabled so
that they're kind of in a position where
you don't have to worry about them
they'll be prone or something like this
or perhaps you'll be body guarding
someone so it's a way of moving around
each other I would not really like to
have my back to someone who are swinging
something sharp or burning so much of
this is almost a method to show how he
feels so you have an expression of
emotion going on in the fight scenes
rather than necessarily being this very
very tight cohesive fight his anger is
always explicit everything is these
white powerful slashes that aren't
necessarily good for defense it's so
heavily stylized I think in things like
the Revenge of the Sith you have these
very very dynamic fight scenes between
obi-wan and Anakin and those I think are
much more expressive a combat even if
the distance is a little bit funny even
if they're standing toe-to-toe and
waving the swords around there's a lot
more aggression and interaction in there
as such I think I'd give it a 5 out of
10
as in it has aspects that I really enjoy
if I was going for my enjoyment of the
fight scene it would be an 8
I really really love the Yoda fight
scenes I always have again it's that
point where you separate any desire for
reality it doesn't have to be real you
know if it's got dragons if it's got the
force it doesn't matter it has to be
something expressive of all the things
you want in there yes absolutely if you
can cut flesh you can cut forever it's
it's again it depends on on different
things like how sharp the sword is but
they are made to cut things and the
horses were very realistic let's give it
a one
[Music]
you